alors il ya une candidate inquiets qui a
été critiquée gars étaient un peu un peu
moqué on va voir leur équipe on en parle
c'est apprécié avec elle elle se
présentait comme une grande warrior est
à peine commencée le jeu qu'elle avait
déjà peu de voix
s'il ya une épreuve inattendue à
laquelle doivent se confronter tous les
aventuriers participant à koh lanta
c'est celle du jugement le jugement des
téléspectateurs qui chaque semaine se
lâche sur les réseaux sociaux
ouais je me sens pas très à l'aise j'ai
pas envie pour l'instant de commencer à
créer des liens avec qui que ce soit
c'est l'amère expérience qui a fait
alexandra durant son aventure moqué sur
son physique jugé trop large et qualifié
de moosch par certains internautes
la jeune femme a décidé de répondre sans
détour j'ai le droit des belles sur
instagram est moche sur koh lanta ou
inversement
avant de lancer à ses détracteurs à toi
qui t'es moquer de ma voix de mon
physique de mon état et encore de ma
voix je n'ai qu'une chose à dire
heureusement que je n'ai pas participé
at the voice ou miss france une réponse
qui a le mérite d'être franche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va pas se mentir c'est
totalement gratuit mais bien ses stands
avancer les choses
vous comprenez évidemment son sa réponse
est plutôt classe d'ailleurs je dois m
qu'est ce que vous avez pu lire sur vous
de plus où la demande
on vous dit quoi ma gueule à moi tout je
crois je crois suis passé par toutes les
étapes
c'est vraiment sans blague mais après on
s'y fait mais je pense que le problème
c'est justement dans ce genre d'émission
que soit de télé réalité ou d' aventure
c'est que les candidats y est l
émergence aujourd'hui des réseaux
sociaux et la méchanceté gratuite sur
les réseaux je pense qu'il faut
absolument préparer les candidats à ce
genre de situation après le post le
poste aventure on va dire ça
voilà parce que c'est bon c'est bon ça
peut être un drame et c'est choquant et
moi quand je reçois des candidats c'est
la première chose que je leur dis avant
que ce soit diffusé
donc ils ont déjà tourné mais c'est pas
encore diffusé lundi attention à ce
qu'il va se passer quand ça va être
diffusé il va se passer ça ça ça et ça
ne t'inquiète pas prend du recul et des
fois je passe une heure à discuter sur
le après parce que c'est traumatisant
même preuve d'ailleurs qu'ils le font
par exemple la production de 4 mariages
pour une lune de miel ce que ça avec les
les participants talent s'en prennent
plein la tête passait tout critiquer
tout et ben en fait avant de participer
quand elles sont acceptées elle
ressemble un petit fascicule est
justement un guide de communication pour
éviter de trop souffrir de tous cas vont
se prendre sur les réseaux sociaux et je
trouve ça super intelligent voilà c'est
je crois que c'est pas tout à fait vrai
ce que vous dites si mais je vous crois
volontiers
pourtant je vous confirme et je suis
très sûr de mon info est-ce que vous
avez des messages pas sympathique sur le
réseau j'en ai vu quand j'ai fait
les émissions avec tir il est de lui
après moi je suis quelqu'un avec mon
handicap
tu as toujours des méchancetés tu as
toujours des regards différents parce
que les gens ont peur de l'inconnu là en
l'occurrence j'ai trouvé ça méchant et
c'est de la méchanceté gratuite qu'elle
soit moche ou qu'elle soit belle on s'en
fout un peu elle est là pour faire un
programme avec des avec des comment dire
des activités sportives et pourquoi
toujours s'attaquer au physique mais
après le jeu de la critique sur twitter
on peut aussi le faire avec mais avec
humour moi que j'avais parfois de dire
des trucs sur twitter qu'est ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il faut pas aller au
delà de ça et puis je suis d'accord avec
magali berna il faut vraiment que les
candidats soient préparés à des choses
comme ça parce que si les gens ils sont
pas forts psychologiquement ça peut être
dramatique